our focus with o'dell is making sure
that you know he recovers from the acl
tear like we want to be healthy and and
you know ready to go next year
but we're we're pleased
you always it's a lot of outside noise
about you know it's almost kind of feels
like a
year to year thing with odell um not
from you guys but again from from the
outside you see him as a you know
long-term
piece uh along with your young core guys
that were drafted by the franchise going
forward yeah you know jake i feel like
this is a question that i've literally
addressed every you know every week
since uh
you know since i took the job so like
you know really at this point in time i
don't i really don't see a
difference look i don't buy that and i
don't like that and let me just say i
don't want to be critical of people who
do the job because you have to have a
relationship with the people you cover
but when they tiptoe into these
questions they create the opening for
the non-answer you heard the way the
question was set up oh this is a lot of
stuff from the outside no it's reality
otto beckham jr has a torn acl he's
moving deeper into his contract what
does this say about his future with the
team that's a fair question it should be
asked directly and when you tiptoe
around it on the way in you set the
stage for an on answer chris well yeah
especially when you do that and but but
you know to andrew barry's point there
you know i've i've already seen them
answer the question a number of times
over the last few weeks so it is a fair
question but he said it nothing has
changed in the meantime and nor or is it
going to change in the meantime you know
at some point you know when we get into
december and start to early january when
they start to think about wait how are
we going to set up our 2021 football
team they'll start to have those
discussions and see and you know then
the off season will start and things
like that and then you know
hey this is out there this is a common
thought across the nfl
and teams might start to call cleveland
and gage odell beckham jr is is there
interest in you guys trading him is his
knee a hundred percent those type of
things was it a normal acl tear all
those type of things so for right now it
is what it is and i think andrew barry
is just a little bit exhausted from
always having to address that same type
of conversation
that's what happens when you have an
odell beckham jr on your team period
it's part of the job you deal with it
and andrew berry is not available to
media every week chris they do a
mid-season thing and i'm surprised
they're doing these general manager
mid-season things this year because it
seems like teams have used the pandemic
as an occasion to restrict access but we
heard from joe douglas earlier this week
we heard from andrew barry that this is
the time of year where some teams will
trot out the gm for a mid-season
conversation with the media and uh that
i don't think they're required to do it
but you know what why not go ahead and
do it especially if you're going to be
asked a bunch of softball tiptoe
questions where you can just not answer
i i feel like this is a question i've
addressed every week since i took the
job doesn't answer the question about
his future and uh oh hey look it's free
country he can give that answer if he
wants and we can react to it if we want
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports